winner. If you're curious about what
LLMs are saying about your company,
about you, about your competitors, it
can be really challenging to figure that
out. It takes me back to the days of
like old old school when we' be like,
"How do we get on Yahoo? How what how do
we rank on Alta Vista? What's LOS doing?
Why haven't they spidered our site yet?
What where do we show up on Excite?"
this pre Google
didn't exist yet. These are old, old
search engines. So, uh, elderly search
engines as it were. So, my friend Carrie
Dhy was like, "Well, I want to know what
LLM are saying about stuff, and I have
businesses who want to know what LLMs
are saying about them or what LLMs are
saying about their competitors. Are they
recommending their competitors more than
they're recommending my business?" So
she built a tool that allows you to
basically do a profile of your company.
It helps you know decide some questions
that it's going to use to identify
whether your company is being fairly
represented by you know claude Gemini
chat GPT and it takes a little wrangling
like you have to get your keys in there
so it can do the lookups and do the
things but then once you've set it it's
kind of set it and forget it. You can go
back on a regular basis and see am I
ranking any better? Am I getting more
views from the LLMs? Are people asking
questions about the type of company I'm
building or the type of solution I'm
delivering? And if you're like, I don't
know if I want to deal with all the keys
and all the techy stuff, the beauty of
this is Carrie will also take the time
to just help you set it up because as I
said, you go through it once and then it
just works and it keeps working and you
can run it and run it again. I ran
Silicon Florist through it and like 60%
of the time it was getting recommended.
I ran me through it, only 30% of the
time was I getting recommended. So that
was interesting and it and it gives me
pause to to kind of think about how I
might be doing a better job with my own
personal brand to ensure that I'm
ranking where I want to be ranking
because I want the the people to find me
through the LLMs. if they're asking
questions, I want to be here to help
them get through their questions. So,
thanks very much to Carrie for building
this. Uh, thanks for offering to help
people set it up. If you're even mildly
curious about where you're ranking in
LLMs, I highly encourage you to check
this out. I of course will link it up
and encourage you to try it as soon as
you can. You